you know i kind of miss robot wars i
don't know i don't know
when it got cancelled is it still a
thing it's probably not still there i
don't think so probably
i don't think battlebots decide this
whole thing either maybelline check that
out yeah it's
one it's one of the few things we had
growing up with that made engineering
look cool
right because because it's really hard
to make engineering look cool
right but you you see you see these like
mechanics that would be
like a really cool way to teach
engineering coding
like an all-in-one thing yeah you get
them to make just a little thing [ __ ]
move around a little bit like why not
teach that
the one thing i loved about uh
battlebots though was just like
just just the fluctuation between like
the different people
that who clearly had completely
different skills in engineering like one
robot was like
this robot is an automated arm that can
you know grab and pick up robots
and then there's another dude's like the
challenger comes in it's like i attached
60 knives onto this point
and the only function you can do is go
forwards and backwards
saw on wheels yeah that's literally it
like it's
so funny and you see like some like
piddly robots that had like the most
depressing flipper of all time i
couldn't even flip my grandma
and then it goes up against like [ __ ]
hypno disc or something it just gets
absolutely destroyed half of them like
don't even move like in practice so it's
just like it's just the door stopper on
wheels
i don't know if battlebots had this but
the uk one had this where like
the the show runners had their own like
ops
robots oh yeah yeah yeah that would just
like when the nothing was happening
they'd be like send out charles or
something like that a lot yeah and
they're like
this just [ __ ] massive clearly like
absolutely got to your engineering world
created
coming back
i'm just getting reminded of all like
these old television shows i used to
watch as a kid now
remember gladiators was was that was
that part of that's very
very old that's very very that's like
90. that sounds really familiar what is
that
it's basically like very much inspired
like
the whole like kind of sporty-esque like
really intense
physical sport yeah it's it's it was
kind of like instead of
like instead of like uh what what's
what are like the shows that like four
guys and stuff is based around
wipeout wipe out so instead of like
going against an obstacle course you'd
have an obstacle course
but then you'd be competing against a
gladiator which was like this kind of
like really
fit muscular person and it that would
have there would be this competitive
element where you'd have to beat
like beat this person like this yeah on
on this obstacle course or something
like that
or definitely just like literally fight
them yeah
that's the final basically you get to
the end he's just standing there
i mean i the best way i can describe it
it's basically something very
it's like wipeouts with uh with
wrestling basically
anyway so it's like so it's like real
time like you're fighting
like or not fighting but like competing
with the gladiators there's like one i
think there's one event in it where like
you both had like the
those like long poles with like cushions
on the end
and you
the platform yeah i remember that i mean
i know that sure is old because like i
think i was watching that like very
early 2000s everyone's wearing like
latex and spandex and i'm like oh yeah
i'm pretty sure all that's just taken
from takeshi's castle right yeah what's
the other one the japanese one's called
like uh i think it was
it's called like um ultimate banzuki or
something
oh yeah yeah i think well like literally
they will do
so this is this show is so fun you
should watch clips on youtube it's
really [ __ ] cool so what they would
do is right is that they would have like
someone either they would be a generic
thing or they'd have an expert so they'd
bring on like
10 expert pogo people and they would
build like a [ __ ] impossible
pogo obstacle course right and they
would have to do it and like the [ __ ]
they would do is insane
yeah and it was always it wasn't just
general people it's like no they get
professionals
and there'd be people who like they'd
have to be um they'd bring people who
are professionals
like handstands yeah and i'd have to do
a whole course
handstand walking around like going
upstairs going on wobbles yeah i've
definitely seen it like
it's really [ __ ] cool you should
watch this just type it in i think it's
i have to
oh my buns again right i think i think
it's cool something like that yeah
and like the stuff they'd have to do was
crazy like they had that um
you know that mario party game where you
have to like there's like seven things
stacked like have a hammer and hit it oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they had a game
where two people had to do that i need
to like get it they just hit them all
out
right but obviously when they hit it
yeah they would like tip the thing over
yeah it was really cool
that's based off like a traditional
japanese like toy yeah yeah